et pour comprendre les difficultés du
passé la californie plus gros état aux
états unis instaure des cours techniques
obligatoires pour être diplômé du lycée
et c'est une première voyez les
explications de ton abonnés notre
correspondant à washington
après plusieurs mois de débats la mesure
a finalement été instaurée par le
gouverneur démocrate de californie à
partir de l'année 2030 les lycéens de
cet état auront l'obligation de suivre
des cours d'études ethniques afin de
valider leur diplôme il s'agit de cours
sur différents groupes ethniques leurs
difficultés au cours de l'histoire
américaine et l'impact de ces événements
sur la situation contemporaine voici
comment est justifié l'instauration de
ce nouveau programme scolaire par le
gouverneur de californie
les cours d'études ethniques permettent
aux étudiants d'apprendre leur propre
histoire et celle de leurs camarades et
un certain nombre d'études ont montré
que ces cours augmente la réussite à
long terme particulièrement parmi les
étudiants de couleurs l'amérique est
structurée par notre histoire partagée
souvent marquée par des injustices
douloureuse les étudiants mairie de se
reconnaître dans leur étude et doivent
comprendre l'histoire complète de notre
nation si nous voulons qu'un jour ils
construisent une société plus juste
évidemment l'instauration de ces cours à
relancer une polémique assez ancien aux
états unis puisqu'il ya régulièrement
des débats sur le contenu des programmes
scolaires américains des débats entre
des conservateurs et des progressistes
qui s'affrontent donc sur ce qu'il faut
enseigner aux plus jeunes ici aux
etats-unis d'ailleurs est l'un des
auteurs de la loi californienne a dit
qu'il espérait que cela pourrait créer
un précédent voir un exemple pour
d'autres et afin qu'il instaurerait
aussi à des programmes similaires lui
qui dans le même temps dit s'inquiéter à
des mesures inverses qui sont prises ces
derniers mois par des états républicains
alors cet affrontement politique autour
du contenu des programmes scolaires aux
états unis est souvent concentrés autour
de la notion de théorie critique de la
race un courant de recherche américain
qui établit qu'il existe un billet
raciale dans les lois et les
institutions
américaine et depuis un moment des
parents plutôt conservateurs accusent
des écoles et des professeurs
d'enseigner cette théorie à leurs élèves
des groupes de parents se sont notamment
constituées sur les réseaux sociaux pour
lutter contre ce qu'ils considèrent
comme des programmes scolaires
idéologiquement biaisée
une pression qui est assimilé à du
harcèlement par cette organisation deux
comités directeurs d'établissements
scolaires qui a adressé ces derniers
jours une lettre à destination du
président des états unis alors que ces
actes de malveillance de violence et les
menaces contre les responsables des
écoles publiques ont augmenté la
classification de ces actions odieuse
pourraient être équivalentes à une forme
de terrorisme intérieur et à des crimes
haineux l'afer est allé si loin que le
département de justice américain s'en
est saisi et à demander formellement au
fbi haye de travailler afin de lutter
contre la hausse de ces phénomènes de
harcèlement et de menaces en promettant
également que des mesures seraient
prises prochainement par les autorités
américaines alors pour les parents
engagés dans cette lutte politique
autour des programmes scolaires le fait
d'être assimilé à du terrorisme
intérieur a évidemment provoqué une très
vive indignation mais finalement les
débats houleux sur la question du
contenu des programmes scolaires aux
états unis est un miroir assez
révélateur sur le fossé gigantesque dans
la population américaine autour de ces
questions sensibles et qui agite les
tensions depuis maintenant déjà
plusieurs années aux états unis